[Music]
well george uh ripping people off
with bad
lending practices predatory lending
practices even when you give it a cool
tech name
is no longer cool that's right buy now
pay later that's what this is all about
i didn't rip anyone off just to be clear
here klarna here's here's the headline
from morning
which means nothing no what's the word
mean nothing nothing it's just a hip hip
it means that now you gonna pay payments
when you should have not bought the
shirt if you couldn't afford the
freaking shirt
oh my god
here's what they're saying klarna's
layoffs signal a broader buy now pay
later slow down oh
feels so bad there's an increase in
common sense
and here's what it goes on to say
these companies are watching their rapid
gains crumble by now pay later giant
klarna europe's largest private tech
firm said yesterday it was laying off
ten percent of the company's roughly
seven thousand
employees
wow
seven hundred people
the dust
uh klarna firm after pay number of these
startups its point of sale installment
loans is what it is last year us
consumers spent over 20 billion dollars
through these services now wait a minute
the ceo says the war in ukraine
what
oh that's what they're they're blaming
it soaring inflation
and likely recession
as reason for the cuts
i i mean
there's
the reason you're cutting
your employees
is because your product is not selling
people didn't quit borrowing money for
their shirt on klarna
because of the ukrainian war
you it's a great reason double ducking
goober
seriously
that's so lame i got breakfast this
here's from after pay my biscuit allowed
me to do four interest-free payments of
375 using after pay on a biscuit
can you believe that
wow biscuit a literal biscuit i was
shocked and uh so here's what's
happening so mr ceo it's not the ukraine
it's the fact that people woke up the
fact you were screwing them and they got
tired of financing their biscuit
this is why you're going to lay people
off there's an
another study says there's an increase
in wisdom and common sense directly
correlated to the loss of clarina's 700
employees oh my god
this is four out of five dentists say if
you brush your teeth they won't fall out
it's amazing how that works so we've
been talking about this before it was
cool steering people away from it we did
a whole episode on the fine print about
buying out yourself george was he was he
was a man i called him he was early to
the party so here's what they're saying
buy now pay later companies are dealing
with another threat regulation numerous
us and uk agencies have launched
investigations into the company's
potentially predatory lending practices
accusing them of irresponsibly allowing
young consumers to rack up debt
wow wait a minute you're saying it's bad
to finance a biscuit
is this what we're saying people they're
finally realizing it's predatory lending
because they try to act like the good
guys that's what frustrates me the most
about your honor i'm in bankruptcy court
today because of my biscuit problem
375 for easy payments first of all
that's an expensive biscuit i gotta say
but here's what happens retailers can
charge more for their products because
the price looks lower to these young
consumers who go well i can fit 375 in
my budget why not i mean it's almost
impossible to pull something up online
right now that they don't go for easy
payments
and you know you're four dollars and
twenty-two you were around when this
originally like you can't
you can't afford any purse print i mean
come on well dave it frees money in my
budget they're they're trying to help
you achieve financial freedom see
ukrainian war
it's throwing everything off
it's insane sorry for the ukrainian or i
don't like it i don't mean that i'm not
making fun of the ukrainian people love
their goods but you can't blame your
company's failures on that no these
companies they they try to act like
they're the good guys in the lending
industry because they go well we don't
do interest we don't do all these fees
we're better than the credit card
companies we're not payday lenders
yeah let me give you the principle okay
1983
take us back
23 years old
i bought a house
believe it or not
for eight thousand dollars wow
i spent 12 thousand dollars to fix it up
it was pretty dumpy so i got 20 000
bucks in this house
i sold it to a guy
for 34 000
who went and got an fha loan this is
it ain't much of a house
even in 83 that's not much of a house
okay
you know what he did
he didn't get the fha loan
his grandpa owning the money
he turned around and he sold this house
that i had 20 in
sold to him for 30 450
to a guy
on payments
zero interest
500 down
wow
now you tell me that's zero interest
because the appraisal on the house was
34.
he sold it for 50.
is that zero interest
no
well the contract said it was zero
interest
this is what klarna does it's a modern
day version of that crap
okay just mark it up
double
mark it up 25
mark it up
18
and then call it no interest
we're not charging any interest how
could we be doing predatory lending
yes you are
boys and girls we've all got different
traps and so not all of them some of
them are interest-free some of them are
fee-free but if you miss a payment that
is where the apr kicks up way higher
than credit cards some of these are 30
apr well and they got more fees than a
french poodle i mean it's fifi
fifi everywhere it's just ridiculous and
they're hoping and banking on the fact
that you won't pay
oh yeah because then they get to really
get you with the late charges
so can you tell that we're not sad that
klarna's not doing well the reason we're
not sad that klarna is not doing well is
clarna doesn't do you well
we don't really care all we want is for
you to win we love you people we want
you to win we're what's known as
consumer advocates we're always going to
be taking up for you telling you that
you're getting screwed here you're
getting screwed there stay away from
these guys they're going to screw you
don't do this it's going to screw you
don't do that if you'll if you'll follow
that if you'll just keep from getting
screwed all the time you'll have some
money what's crazy is that they're not
going after the credit card companies
these you know these agencies but
they're going after buying out pay later
that tells you something about how
scummy these companies are and how
predatory they are
capital one's not you know they've got
certain levels of regulation but these
buy now pay later companies here's what
they do to avoid regulation they do four
payments instead of five because once
you do five
now truth and lending there's the truth
and lending act that kicks in whoa i did
not know isn't that wild
fun fact interesting information and
their marketing goes after lower income
it goes after minorities and so they're
starting to get goes after the young and
stupid
gen z if you're young and you're stupid
i was just talking to you yeah
so you don't have to be done you don't
have to be stupid if you're young and
you don't have to be young if you're
stupid that's true you could be either
one or both
but boy if you're both you are a target
of these people you're the one financing
a biscuit if you're financing a biscuit
you might be stupid
if you're financing a shirt
you might be stupid
you got 17 in the closet
unbelievable